أنباء عن قتال عنيف وغارات جوية في
كل أنحاء غزة يوم السبت
هناك اشتباكات عنيفة بين أه حماس
وجنود إسرائيليين حول
مخيم جباليا للاجئين شمال
غزة باتجاه الجزء الأوسط من
القطاع أنباء عن غارات جوية أه على مبنى فيه
نحو 150 شخصا
وفقًا للسكان، الذين
جاء العديد منهم من
الجزء الشمالي من غزة هربًا من القتال هناك،
كانت هناك مشاهد فوضوية حيث تم
نقل جثث القتلى والجرحى
إلى مستشفى محلي، لكن
القتال الأشد كان شديدًا لدرجة أن  لقد رأينا
على مدار الأيام القليلة الماضية ما حدث
في حونيس وما حولها، وهي
أكبر مدينة في جنوب غزة،
وتقول إسرائيل إنها تخترق
الخطوط الدفاعية لحماس هناك، وأنهم
يتنقلون من منزل إلى منزل ويحاولون
تطويق المدينة.  لأن هذا هو
المكان الذي يعتقد المسؤولون الإسرائيليون أن
العديد من كبار قادة حماس قد يتواجدون فيه في
نفس الوقت ليلة السبت، أصدر الجيش الإسرائيلي
ما أسموه نداءً عاجلاً
للسكان والمدنيين للفرار أه
خمسة أجزاء محددة جدًا من الحونيس صدر
أمر إخلاء أه  يقول جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
إن هؤلاء
المدنيين الفلسطينيين يجب أن يذهبوا إلى المنطقة السادسة
المشار إليها على الخريطة، وقد نشروا ذلك على
الإنترنت، ومن غير الواضح عدد
المدنيين هناك الذين لديهم
اتصال بالإنترنت، وكم منهم سوف يرون
ذلك، وكم من الأشخاص الذين يعرفون كيفية التحقق من ذلك
القنوات الإسرائيلية أه الجيش الإسرائيلي يقول أنه
يجب عليهم الإخلاء إلى منطقة
جنوب غرب حونس لإنشاء ملاجئ
كما أنه من غير الواضح ما هي الملاجئ الموجودة
بالفعل هناك آلاف الأشخاص
فروا إلى أقصى الجنوب من حوناس
باتجاه مدينة رفح حيث توجد
ملاجئ وهي  بالفعل
الناس مكتظون ينامون في
الشوارع ليس هناك ما يكفي من الوقود والغذاء والماء
أه الهلال الأحمر الفلسطيني
قال إن حوالي 100 شاحنة
عبرت أه من مصر إلى غزة يوم
السبت وهذا لا يزال أقل من متوسط
عدد الشاحنات التي رأيناها قادمة  إلى
غزة خلال أه تلك الهدنة التي استمرت 7 أيام
وفقًا لمسؤولي الأمم المتحدة، فقد أصبح
حوالي
85% من سكان غزة
مشردين الآن وتقول وزارة الصحة التي تسيطر عليها حماس
في غزة إن
177,000 شخص قتلوا منذ
7 أكتوبر Alex markwart CNN Tel
Aviv